cup is exciting to watch but it's even
better to watch with your friends and
Huffer House Las Vegas is the ultimate
game destination to catch all the world
cup action now here to tell us more is
our friend Jessica from the Hofer house
good to see you good to see you too
thanks for having me well first off it's
always a party over there but it's extra
special right now with with the games
going on what do you have taking place
it is so exciting so we open at 10 A.M
for all the England Germany and Mexico
games okay because the games are at 11
so we open an hour early so Friday
morning 10 a.m will be open because USA
starts at 11. yes they play England on
Friday then we watch uh Mexico on
Saturday and then Spain Germany on
Sunday and what kind of specials are
taking place we have the beer garden you
have beer specials what's going on you
know we have TV set up in the beer
garden and the main hall throughout the
entire main hall we added in the eight
TVs
so you're not going to miss any of the
actions no someone's watching and
they've got a bunch of friends they want
to come down for the game should we make
a reservation or just show up what's the
action like you should go online or call
702 853 beer to make a reservation but
you can also walk in feel free to
um but it's going to be packed it is
going to be hundreds of fans I know it's
so exciting too because fans are rooting
for different countries USA England now
come Sunday the big Germany the big
Germany Germany game who are you rooting
for
Germany still of course of course I know
it was not fun this morning to watch
them lose but look at you we're showing
the excitement this is the chaos that's
happening from 2018. look at the madness
that's taking place when you see your
team win at home it's great but when you
see your team win with a lead and a
fellow fans it's even better yes it is
for sure so what'd you bring today we
brought the original and the Dunkle in
our soccer boot oh which is this
chicken purchase in the gift shop and
then drink your favorite German beef so
you said there's drink out of this all
day long while you're watching them
watch some games we serve beer
Micheladas different cocktail Styles and
we have the full menu available well
cheers it's gonna be great weekend
and also too I can't let you go without
you brought your famous pretzels too the
pretzel imported from Germany with our
obatsa the sweet mustard and the
homemade spicy onion mustard oh these
are the real deal right here and this
beer is delicious now real quick too
tomorrow is Thanksgiving someone's
watching right now I'm like oh my gosh I
forgot I forgot to cook are you having
Thanksgiving meals tomorrow and
everything what's going on absolutely we
have 28 turkeys cooking are you serious
there's 28 turkeys there's hundreds of
people enjoying because we do the
cooking and then the guests do the
eating and one of the turkeys is England
right because USA is going to win on
Friday yes 100 unless you're ready for
England don't be mad at me but you know
I'm on Patriot what can I say well thank
you so much for joining us Jessica
really appreciate it's a lot of fun
Happy Thanksgiving Happy Thanksgiving so
this week marks the anniversary